espn um espn reporter in the nba
and certainly so much uh as to writ
large
uh going on in the real world with the
nba including
uh this man's moving interview with the
father
of jacob blake dave mcmanaman back here
on the rich eisen show from the bubble
how are you dave
i'm doing well rich thanks for having me
on thanks for thanks for joining
how close was the nba to not returning
and playing these playoffs that resumed
this weekend
as close as it can get i i think is the
right way to put it
wednesday night when there was that
three-hour long players meeting
that had no resolution and ended with
the lakers and clippers leaving the room
basically saying like
hey if this is where things are going
then
we're done uh there was a very real
moment
where the only path forward would be to
continue to not play games because
basically there was trying to fill in
meaning
for the buck's decision after the fact
and you know i've spoken to so many
people over the last four or five days
and
no one wants to disparage the bucks
because they
believe that their mind and their hearts
were in the right place
but there was also the very real
recognition that
everyone down here in orlando that you
know many of the
the players and and team members have
been down here for
close to two months at this point there
was a
joint purpose together to do so
and that was you know involving many
meetings with the nba players
association
it involved a 170 million dollar
financial commitment by the nba to make
this bubble happen
um it involved sacrifices in terms of
leaving
one another's families et cetera et
cetera and
there was purpose behind that and what
the bucks did while it certainly
there was a purpose in the moment there
it was missing the big picture
and so you know after some frustrations
were vented and
i think that some of that was just the
product of this schedule down here it's
been such a grind
everyone got a chance to you know kind
of
release that tension and then recognize
okay we can do something with this
moment
and uh there was a players and owners
call on thursday and
some plans were put into place and and
we're back we're back on
well and as as always dave as you know
very well from your your tenure
um covering him in cleveland it's
it's a lebron world where many of us
just rent payers
in it um and the the reporting has been
that
uh lebron uh was distressed that the
bucks made this maneuver kind of by
themselves without realizing that it
would reflect the entire league
completely and there had not been any
uh any other forethought as to how it
would end like what was the
end game and he reached out to barack
obama is
is this all the the proper reporting in
terms of lebron's role
in this yeah i mean it's lebron's role
but lebron
alongside chris paul i think has to be
mentioned
certainly when you bring up the obama
meeting you know chris paul being the
players association president
and being so instrumental in getting
this thing off the ground to begin with
um lebron and chris paul it's described
to me a small group of players so there
are other players involved but
yes they thought the council of barack
obama
and what i've reported is that
obama's message was listen fellas don't
walk away from this moment
continue to play but before you're going
to play make sure
that there is a conversation and a plan
in place
to get even more commitment from the nba
to help you and help you know our
country in the pursuit
of equality and it's not to say that the
nba hadn't
done a lot because the owners committed
300 million dollars over the next 10
years
to you know donate towards causes to
help block financial equality
as well as you know opportunities right
and of course the messaging on the
jerseys and
black lives matter on the court but what
more can we do
and so three items one every nba arena
is going to be changed into a mass
voting center
for the upcoming election in november
two there's going to be
advertisements aired on every playoff
broadcast
focused on voter engagement and
bringing awareness to the suppression
that is going on in this country right
now
and three a social justice coalition
will be formed
with the support of the league and
involving people on all levels
players coaches front office executives
um and so all these people
can be engaged and bringing
conversations that they're having within
their own silo of the nba
to a mutual conversation in order to
effect change
so um let's pull a little bit of a
string on what anthony davis had to say
saying that if the owners don't come
through um then we're not going to play
anymore
so i mean i don't want to he said that
everything went well
but we do know some owners in the nba
the owner of the knicks
um dolan what if he gets a call from
uh the president and it's like don't do
that with madison square garden we all
know the devos family owns the magic
um and the current secretary of the edge
of education
is betsy devos what happens if if this
does in fact
not materialize for all 30
member clubs dave what happens there yes
certainly rich and it's uh prudent that
you mentioned the devos family because
when anthony was posed that question
by dylan hernandez of the la times
he brought up the the post family and
said like hey
look at their track record what would
lead anyone to believe that they would
commit to this and
anthony davis echoed the same message
that lebron james said he said
they have given us their word and
as a man i'm going to respect that word
but if they go against it
they have to know that there will be
repercussions and we are ready to walk
away
we already showed that we walked away
temporarily for
three days this past week and so i
i don't know the answer here rich i i
you know
you would think that everyone involved
would
have a big picture perspective here and
recognize that
if they do mess with this like not only
is that
going to affect potentially their own
business but it would affect
the entire nba as we know it you know
there's a lot of things changing in
today's
sports landscape and um
i think there could be dire consequences
if if there was a long work stoppage and
so
uh i don't anticipated going there but i
think anthony davis
which is also a story about his coming
of age this season you know he's
27 years old now and really coming into
his own as one of the the true
bright spots in this league uh not just
for his play
um but but for his voice off the court
as well well and again
i don't i'm not trying to stir anything
up i'm just you know that this is
obviously
a very sensitive subject and and uh when
when a
player of anthony davis's stature says
if it doesn't happen we don't play
um and something might happen after the
season is over
this clearly could linger into 2020 2021
although
you know voting should be something that
is nonpartisan anyway and we're excited
to have
some form of a democratic norm in terms
of voting and
this this should all help out dave
mcmenamin here on the rich eisen show
what about
jacob blake senior what did you glean
from that conversation and the blake
family
potential role in in in the
conversations that occurred wednesday
through friday dave yeah jacob jacob
lake senior first of all
just remarkable spirit i
can't imagine the whirlwind that it must
have felt like to not only
process the fact that your son is now
paralyzing waist down but you were
grieving uh process or
you know your your struggle is being
played out for not just the country to
see not
but the world to see and i i was just
pulled over
by his his grace and his
recognition that you know things
will get better because they have to get
better and
also his his gratitude gay
to care about his story uh he told me
i i i think this might have been a
little bit of a hyperbole but he told me
barely five minutes had passed since the
bucks
left the court for good in their game
that they
decided not to play against orlando
magic when he had a phone call
and it was the bucks on the line and
they
they told him from their own voices what
they were doing
in order to stand up against the police
brutality
that was nexted upon his son and he said
he started crying
and then he said giannis antocoupo
started crying in front of the entire
team
and he said it touched him deeply and
that support
he said is something that has helped him
get through this past week because
it was just eight days ago when jacob
blake
29 year old black man was shot seven
times in the back
by kenosha wisconsin police
no matter what the background behind
that story was
you know what the police were responding
to
that's not the role of police officers
in our society
they are not judge and jury they are not
executioners
they are keepers of the peace and
he just said that his spirits have been
lifted
it's fueled him in order to continue to
do things like
leave his family temporarily to fly down
to washington for the
march on washington and speak about his
family's story
to try to continue to touch
hearts and minds of people in this
country who don't
quite understand how vital equality
truly is for us to have
a working and functioning democracy
so just to revisit
five minutes after the bucks say
we're not playing and you know your
colleague at the times mark stein
in an interview with michael carter
williams of the magic said carter
williams got a text from giannis
basically saying we're not coming we're
not coming out of the uh the locker room
again because it was bucks in orlando
and that's the way the magic kind of
learned about it that
they'd make this decision and say let's
get jacob blake senior on the phone
as a team that happened last week
that happened yeah and then furthermore
later on that night
when the 13 teams still here in orlando
had that contentious meeting where
everybody put everything out on the
table and you know they started the
meeting by inviting the blake family
to join in on zoom now there are some
technical difficulties but
the intention was
we want your guidance on what we should
do here and
jacob blake senior told me that i mean i
i he said he was floored by that gesture
he said these are
you know these are young men with their
own livelihoods who am i to tell them
what to do
but even the fact that they saw his
input
meant so much to him because it was you
know recognizing him
seeing him believing that
he had some wisdom that could help their
situation
dave mcmahon here uh on the rich eisen
show uh nba insider from espn and he
spoke to jacob blake senior
as part of the coverage of the return of
the playoffs over the weekend few more
minutes left with uh
dave from the bubble so let's talk uh
briefly i guess
about some hoops so um
anthony davis and lebron james together
were just remarkable
in that first round that's exactly what
the lakers hoped
they would get from these two guys who
uh
we've got the we've got the uh numbers
on the screen i mean lebron averaged a
triple-double
and anthony davis was almost averaging
30
points a game and almost shot 40
from three i mean this is exactly what
they were drawn up when they put this
these two guys together and then kawhi
doing what he was
supposed to do we know the bucks doing
what they do
the celtics destroyed the raptors in
their first game the first
second round game being played is this
wide open
or do you think this is still the lakers
tournament because of those two guys we
just showed on the screen
dave the lakers looked tremendous
after game one of that series and
certainly i think anyone who had
some concerns in the seating round those
thoughts have been
uh you know diminished because really
what happened the lakers didn't play any
games that mattered for a month
and with a veteran group that going
through these unique circumstances
that just didn't produce their best
basketball but when
you know when they had to lay things
online in a playoff situation they look
like the team that we remember back from
march but the clippers are really good
those other teams you mentioned i mean i
don't think anyone's played boston right
now i don't think anyone wants to play
miami i think this miami
milwaukee series which starts off
tonight down here in orlando is going to
be tremendous
now of course jimmy butler you know
hopefully he's over that shoulder injury
that limited him in the pacer series in
the first round but but if he's right
the amount of switchable bodies that
they have
in bama the bio and andre wadala and
jake crowder that they can throw at
giannis
and the amount of shooting that they
have and tyler hero
and duncan robinson goran dragic right
down the list that's a formidable
opponent and
you know i think lakers are right there
at the top of the conversation of who
should win this thing
but i'm not eliminating the rockets from
that conversation i'm not limiting the
celtics
i'm not even eliminating the raptors
after they lost game one of the celtics
there's six teams right now that you
could convince yourself
into saying they'll be the champion uh
six out of eight
that'll be in the second round i mean
that's as much parody as we
pretty much ever see in the nba which
makes these
this next you know six weeks ahead of us
pretty exciting yeah i mean we've got
uh the rockets trying to close out the
thunder tonight
um westbrook returned looked a little
bit rocky from the floor
as we all know and you mentioned heat
and bucks that's those are the two games
tonight
on our friends at turner um just harden
is
so unstoppable i mean and the rockets
just
they're a fascinating team to me
obviously with d'antoni potentially
um what what is the deal with that why
is d'antoni not signed and
pacers basically have put a bouquet of
roses i don't know if you can if you can
do that in the
is there a florist in the bubble i don't
know if they've done that
before they departed but uh what is
going on
yeah that's a good way to put it but
yeah they made their
intentions so clear you know almost
immediately after the ink was drying on
the
press release that nate mcmillan would
be relieved as head coach
they put their intentions out there
listen i mean
i i don't i don't know i mean tim
mcmahon has done great reporting on
what went down there i think mcnaitoni
is a certain
stage of his career where he wants
some security feels like he earned it i
believe he earned it tillman fertitta
is a relatively new owner in the nba and
i to me didn't follow kind of the the
normal
flow of business how these things work
with an accomplished coach in terms of
seeking a but but some team will hire
him and he's made it clear that he wants
to continue coaching it's not time for
him to walk away
but i mean the thing is right now that's
kind of
giving a little bit of a last dance
you know to the this team that they have
there and sometimes that works
yes it does daryl damore
is in an interesting spot we'll see what
happens with him
uh continuing as the executive of that
team
and my fan tony and you know
the the recognition for guys like james
harden and russell westbrook
when will we ever have a coach that
goes all in on an idea like small ball
where
we're going to shoot 63s a game and
that's what
what he wants out of us that's not too
much and i
i think that you know that can add to
that mix uh in terms of like
let's do this thing so i i i think
they're a dangerous team and they got to
get through okc first but they're
they're going to be a handful for the
lakers last one for you dave and i
appreciate your time dave mcmanaman here
from espn who's jamal murray for people
who need a primer
this guy who's just been so dynamite
forcing a game seven
uh in the nuggets jazz series
yeah he's a a young canadian basketball
point guard combo guard grew up with
steve nash as a mentor and he went to
kentucky
you know known for just a ridiculous
work ethic
and a supreme confidence and got this
super max extension
that seemed at times like an anvil
around his neck
because would he live up to this dollar
amount you know he's gonna make
five million dollars this year bump up
to 30 next year is he a 30 million
dollar player
and he's doing things in these playoffs
that we've never seen i mean
him and donovan mitchell both have two
50-point games
in this series heading into game seven
and
i think only two times in the history of
nba four michael jordan did it twice in
a series alan iverson did it twice in
this series
and what murray did with the weight of
what the last four or five days meant to
him
and the players in this bubble last
night where he drops 50 points
21 points in the fourth quarter seventh
grade from the field five for five from
three
and does an interview with nba tv
afterwards or turner afterwards
and he has george floyd painted on one
sneaker and brianna taylor's painted on
the other one and he breaks down the
tears talking about
how he just really wants to win he wants
to win as a basketball player and he
wants to win
as a black man it was powerful stuff
and it's great to see
you know from the basketball side new
players
new talent new stars infusing the system
but it's also great to see young men
come into
who they are um jamal murray i think a
lot of people
will pay attention to him moving forward
i think there's going to be reasons to
pay attention
not just for the buckets that he scores
but for what he says
after after the game dave great chat i
always appreciate it
appreciate the time you gave the show uh
today and as always we'll chat with you
down the line
sounds great you got it that's it
everyone check out dave mcmanaman's
interview with uh jacob blake senior
it's on espn.com and check out obviously
dave's material
on twitter and on instagram